there's one huge step and that is
putting a price on carbon emissions it's
it's really that simple if we put a
gradually increasing price on carbon
emissions by putting a tax at the source
at the mine or at the port of entry
where the fossil fuel is imported to our
country then as that price rises then
energy efficiency renewable energies
nuclear power the other forms of carbon
free energy can compete more effectively
against the fossil fuels but in order
for the public to accept this and in
order for the public to have the money
to invest in a new vehicle and
insulating their home we have to give
all of this money to the public if we
put a price on carbon equivalent to one
dollar a gas a gallon of gasoline that
would generate 670 billion dollars in
one year in the United States if you
return this to the public to legal
residents of the united states that
would be three thousand dollars per
adult legal resident and if you give
half a share to children up to two per
family that's nine thousand dollars per
family with two or more children so that
would give the public the money to make
the changes in their lifestyle that are
needed to move us off of fossil fuels
into a cleaner future because right now
the fossil fuels are the main source of
air pollution pollution which is killing
in the United States about forty to
fifty thousand people per year worldwide
a much larger number than that because
the pollution is much worse in China and
India than it is in the United States so
we have many reasons to want to move
beyond the fossil fuel era
it could happen very easily if our
governments would move in that direction
and by the way if this has happened it
is happening now in British Columbia
Canada they have imposed a carbon tax
with the money returned to the public
they do it via a decrease in payroll
taxes I would rather see a dividend
because half the people are not on a
payroll either they're retired or
they're out of work but you could use
say half of it for a payroll tax
deduction and half of it for a dividend